hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to alternate watch a fan
game inspired by the Mandela catalog and
I'm on observation Duty and as you know
I am very good at observation Duty that
may not be entirely true anomaly Ze
imagery displacement mimic flawed
[Music]
blonde pure form preacher electrical
hole ball corpse unknown open doors are
not displacements it means someone has
entered the home but that's bad okay
so monochrome or color kind of want
color everything's always so monochrome
I kind of want to see things in color
but if it's garbage wait dark mode
dark mode dark mode okay whatever sure
I'll do that oh dark mode yeah it dark
ah okay so I actually have a flashlight
I'm never gonna remember this because
it's in dark mode oh my God I'm not ah
man
thread level vague
you goddamn right it's vague I don't
know what you're talking about
Oh weird
I don't like this
uh okay I'm trying to do my scanning
method but this is such an unfamiliar
environment ah oh God
ah yeah no joke this is using
Unreal Engine fives
[Music]
illumination oh
oh I hate this okay I wasn't expecting
much
um but God damn uh
uh all right oh that's a problem
uh Bob type I don't know what you mean
type three
electrical in the living room I think
oh great good
it's right I don't even know
[Music]
thank you
wow okay well that one was easy because
it just made itself known to me great
that guy was always grumpy that was
always broken laptop was always there
I don't know I wasn't looking at that
this is horrible why did I do dark mode
oh
God
what is wrong with me
why would I do this to myself
I don't know
if
have no idea
him who is him now what did he say about
Open Doors
[Music]
open doors just
oh God that's so weird I keep forgetting
that the lighting system in Unreal
Engine 5 is really good because it's
reflecting the color of this bag I
thought that there was like blood on the
walls or something
[Music]
Threat Level evident
thread level evident it's not evident to
me
what do you mean evident
[Music]
Threat Level is evident
uh well okay then
why don't you evident me some evidence
evident evident
is it evident
oh
evident evident evident what is that
always property oh too many anomalies
I would love to be able to handle it but
I don't even know what I'm looking for
[Music]
huh
huh God okay
got the sweep uh is much less effective
when I can't even see everything in here
okay
trying to see
right away okay maybe the blocks I
probably do have to remember the blocks
Stars
same
that looks roughly the same
thread level vague those arrangements
there are probably important that
picture
property of Dave a big paddle is over
there
basement there's a clock on the bottom
of the basement you see Kettle parrots
plates uh
I just need to look at the shapes that's
really what I'm looking for is The
Shapes of Things
as long as the shapes of things are okay
then generally speaking I can be
pretty okay
shapes
bucket of paint
clock
oh boy
is there always two stacked on there
mimic well I don't remember there being
two but I'm not sure
probably wrong about that
also I
[Music]
I am amazing I am amazing I forgot how
God damn smart I was I forgot how just
unbelievably incredible I was my God I'm
wait a minute
uh
uh imagery something's wrong with that
picture there that's not right that
wasn't that
it's a lot of anomalies
I think anyway yep thank you
man that's a lot of anomalies
what the hell was that
[Music]
the hell okay but that's probably I'm
I'm just gonna get lucky from there on
out uh man I'm not gonna be able to keep
track of that stuff that's not right
uh
were there always two brushes I didn't
look deep enough on that
just gonna put mimic there just in case
I don't think there is but just in case
it might just be like a two an hour kind
of thing never mind
what oh my God I'm amazing
holy crap
I'm incredible
I'm outstanding
good God I'm amazing but that's probably
the best I'm gonna get
for now
[Music]
what does BPS stand for it's on the
shirt and it was on like a mug or
something
brain's trying to latch on to little
details here and there if something was
weird about that last room I know that
was up with his eye was that right
is that right
something something's going on with his
eyes that I didn't notice before
I don't know it's just calling to me
no I thought I had that
uh what do you mean too many and um I've
been knocking down so many anomalies
I knocked down like three what do you
mean
what do you mean oh my God
oh
happy birthday
okay let's try that again
this is horrifying
this is just another level of awful
[Music]
no no oh did that change did the pants
change in some way
feels like it might have something felt
different in here but I guess not it
looks all the same
oh plate is missing
[Music]
displacement
what
there's a plate missing
unknown
flawed unknown uh
I don't know
unless that was the anomaly
that might have been the anomalies that
that was
that plate wasn't there I thought it was
supposed to be there
oh
oops
hey wait a minute ah this is moderately
horrifying
what are you doing there
oh
thank you
what
what just changed what happened did
something change in here
[Music]
I don't know something changed
I don't like it
oh I don't like it
[Music]
oh boy well
I'm boned I must have just got lucky
those first few times definitely just
got lucky
oh
whoa wait a minute wait a minute that's
not right holy crap
yeesh that uh picture right there is uh
looking at me funny
it's kind of looking at me funny
thank you
not that the picture itself is looking
at me any better
uh basement is not fun
oh wait a minute displacement in the
baby room
[Music]
that's not supposed to be there
oh oh one
thank you
this is a really good
uh observation Duty
type game
this one's got the right Vibes and I
haven't even seen anything too creepy
I am anyway
[Music]
I'm missing something
oh I don't know what though
[Music]
a thread level evident it's not that
evident
uh excuse me
oh wait uh in the kitchen
um mimic there's three instead of two
right there yeah I'm opening my eyes
please let me get to the reporting
before you kill me or fire me
thank you with at least that's one down
it's about to go right back up I know
that
trying to open my eyes man I'm trying
harder than you'd think
much harder than you'd think I there's
probably like something moved in here
but I don't even know what does tulpa
mean again
I don't know what tulpa means
[Music]
damn I'm screwed God damn it I don't
even want to know what I'm seeing in the
darkness there I gotta like clean my
monitor just so I could be able to see
things properly okay let's try it again
all right what was I missing before one
apple played knives
uh three things on the table there three
things there five things there
okay this was all fine I haven't noticed
a single change here but maybe that's my
mistake
belongs are the same there
everything's there two bottles there
guitar there was a guitar missing
mimicry in the bathroom there's two
toothbrushes definitely not happening in
this place
definitely not happening
what did I just see Oh I thought I saw
something
oh
oh that's not right something
something's going on there I don't think
that was like that
tiny detail but I'm pretty sure that's
true
[Music]
thank you yeah that's right
is that always a spoon that's such a
weird thing to say but I'm not gonna
doubt anything even something as small
as a spoon could be changed for all I
know
[Music]
or what do you mean what do you mean
what did you just do
what did you do
[Music]
I'm just saying displacement and I'm
just gonna go with that I don't know
what something happened in the basement
and I I didn't catch it
oh God no
I must say imagery I don't know maybe
there was a corpse here and I just
didn't oh mimicry in the in the living
room God damn it
two plants there was not two plants
before oh
[Music]
wait a minute
was there always a pillow in the crib
there
might have been but some doesn't feel
right about it
[Music]
damn it
oh frick
frick
I got to pay attention to the flooring I
totally forgot that the flooring can be
a thing
maybe it was I don't know I'm just gonna
say the basement is flawed because God
it is
[Music]
oh God hi
stop
don't do that
there's something going on in the
basement oh wait nope wait displacement
and that is a tiny detail the spoon is
moved
I think I looked at it before
I know thread level evident oh mimicry
in the laundry room
okay that's good
[Music]
got that
thank you okay thread level vague I
actually got a what happened what did
you do
does that mean something happened in
this uh mimicry in the baby or uh the
bedroom two briefcases
don't like that
[Music]
actually knocking it down
so if it does do that that means it did
change in that room which means the
basement something's going on with it
I I don't know what I'm gonna say mimic
but
I don't know maybe oh maybe two boxes up
there that might be it
so if there are two things next to each
other that are that was it oh
oh I have a chance
God damn so if there's two things next
to each other a slightly different sizes
what happened what'd you do something uh
what displacement in the baby room okay
that's easy enough
oh
[Music]
got that one good thank you
thank you very much
so long as these anomalies don't do any
harm to me I'm perfectly happy
but why does that still not fixed
did you change the same thing again
thank you
weird
[Music]
what was that
oh
displacement in the basement
[Music]
all right
they're moving quick
whoever they are
thank you
[Music]
to find my God I think cheek is sniffing
at the door behind me
scared the out of me
haven't seen one in a spell I'm probably
missing one
tell
[Music]
clue
evident evident evident my ass
nothing evident here God damn it
what am I missing
oh what am I missing
ah I don't know
I'm trying to to open my eyes
[Music]
uh
oh imagery in the basement God damn it
oh there goes my phone I did something
picking up my phone
I don't know how that happened that was
just a lucky guess
[Music]
thank you all right good
we're back on track somehow
don't know how
but we are
[Music]
just gonna move a little quicker
oh thread level evident I don't know
displacement in the living room I'm just
gonna say that
I know it's not true in my heart of
hearts
[Music]
God damn it
I say displacement in the bedroom
because I got nothing better to do with
my life
I'm doomed
I must say displacement in the stairwell
because again
I'm doomed
I'm doomed frick frick sassafras
[Music]
I made it to three that's a new record
at least
we've got to be somewhat happy about me
for me
to me
oh wait mimic oh God I see it
there's multiple books God damn it it's
mimic frick
oh please let me report that that'd be
really nice of you
thank you wow I can't believe you did
that
I'm just gonna say a mimic here
still in it somehow I feel like
something's changed in the kitchen that
should be a lot more obvious than it is
[Music]
of course it's not
same mimic in the living because
frickify really no oh image has changed
imagery
frick frick let me do it ah come on
oh never mind
that was apparently two anomalies in
here because that's different I think
unless I'm crazy
I'm not crazy
[Music]
living room is having a ball today when
the caller has a fire related emergency
contact our neighboring fire at the
apartment
how am I still alive that I don't know
okay
all right
oh man that was it was like two books
right there that was the anomaly that's
how small it was
[Music]
um what
I'm just gonna report something
don't know what
gave me goosebumps well that's a problem
[Music]
that's a problem oh that's a there's an
error code
maybe that's an unknown I don't know
what that would be is that an electrical
or is that an unknown
oh good great
good
[Music]
I'm just gonna say something probably
moved here and I just can't tell
oh
thank you
something's going on electrical in the
baby room they're having a rave in there
every kid needs um
enrichment
[Music]
great
good
goodness goodness
oh there's duplication in the bathroom
well so far nothing deadly
there's just some goofing
this is just some goofs
just some silly Goofs Happening Here
nothing serious
nothing that someone like me with oh
there's definitely something going on
mimicry or displacionary
in the living room uh coffee table's a
little crowded and that's a little empty
yeah I wouldn't say that uh I'm in any
danger
[Music]
great
nope we having more displacement here
that's not supposed to be up there or
something's supposed to be here
[Music]
Bing damn I'm good
these are really tiny details
I'm actually kind of surprised at just
how Teensy
the things that are changing are
you get back why do you keep wanting to
move that that tape wants to be moved
real bad
[Music]
thank you
I'm keeping it at vague which is
shocking
oh my gorgeous
moved
[Music]
I feel like something is displaced there
but I'm not 100 sure
just doing it just in case
unless I'm gonna be penalized well there
you go
still thread level vague
something feels wrong in the baby room
that's that triangles that something
feels wrong there
what no something felt wrong there I
don't know what but something felt wrong
that's not right oh God
okay I knew something was wrong I just
didn't know what
up mimicking the stairwell two tapes
great
oh okay
all right once again have not seen
anything super crazy
but I'm doing good
[Music]
yeah I knew it
okay now I really feel like I'm missing
some wait a minute
Don't You Move That Soap don't even
think about moving that soap
I ain't about that
[Music]
I ain't about
all right
frick
I'm getting close
almost there
just a little bit more
will be golden
oh my God oh my what you what what is oh
my God is that a flaw what is what is
the uh flood is it a preacher and what
is that
what is that
don't even think about it
[Music]
dude okay I removed it how did you
remove it
oh my God
[Music]
wait a minute whoa whoa whoa okay I
thought for a second now why do I have
that menu still up all the time that was
really obscuring my view
that was making it very difficult to see
what I needed to see
oh Apple's missing
where'd that Apple go where'd you put
that Apple did you move that up did you
eat that Apple I really hope you didn't
eat that apple
oh my God
good
oh goodness gracious that painting don't
look gray or a picture that don't look
right
oh
[Music]
I ca I can't believe there hasn't been
something standing oh get the apple back
[Music]
look
at all this
woof all right I win you lose
I win you lose
you wow is that blood okay I remember
[Music]
I did it
hey
[Music]
just my duty as a
citizen of this great country
uh
huh
oh man
overdriven assimilation great
I won
or did I win
missing polish how
cloaked figure obscured and constant
Whispering
um
the unknown cannot be classified yeah I
don't know if that doesn't help doesn't
help at all but anyway that was
alternate watch that was a very good one
I've dabbled in a few of these uh I'm on
observation Duty uh fan games I guess
this is a good one I love dark mode
that's crazy and and using um
use I'm just I just want to see it in
the day well the Day quote unquote
uh and oh man this would have been so
much better
oh this would have been oh this would
have been oh my God can you imagine
can you imagine oh can you imagine oh I
cannot imagine
something is missing there
okay toddler stress assessment record
your child's responses to the following
media anyway
I'm out of here thank you everybody so
much for watching if you want to play
this for yourself and give it a try uh
there's plenty of anomalies I didn't
even see I only saw flawed I didn't see
pure form preacher tulpa corpse unknown
I just got a bunch of display
mimics and imagery one flawed and that
was enough for me I'm happy with that so
thank you
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below and if you want to see
more of I'm on observation Duty let me
know I've actually only played two games
out of it
although the last one was pretty good
and I hope there's another on the way
it's a weirdly fun way to play so thank
you and as always
I will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
I just had a thought
this game and this game type this
element of gameplay is what I wanted out
of Five Nights at Freddy's that it was
never able to nail you're looking at
security cameras you're watching things
but as you get farther in Five Nights at
Freddy's you lose the ability to even
look at the cameras in the first place
this would give you a reason to I think
the more if if people will still make
them in the future Five Nights at
Freddy's fan games are those types of
games this is a mechanic to introduce
anyway I'm out bye
[Music]